- I'm pretty busy.
(group laughter)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, mother
fuckers. I've been telling you.
("Don't Leave Me" by Nik Dinev)
I really love the office and
I really hate Yudkin.
(group laughter)
I didn't realize how
fancy our lawyer was.
You can find stuff there to
flip on Facebook marketplace.
- [Eric] This is Rich.
- [Gary] Hey Rich.
What's the best thing?
What's the most
challenging thing?
- [Rich] The most challenging
thing was (censored) uneducated.
- Right.
And are they just
making subjective calls?
- [Rich] Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- So we're dealing with that.
We had some social content ideas
and unfortunately they've kind
of been taken off the radar
and the client's keen to do
highlights from events that
they're doing which wouldn't
make a splash on social.
- Right.
It's really unbelievable
how unemotional
I've become about that.
I don't think we ever waiver
from giving the right advice
because that's what our job is.
What can I answer for you?
- [Rich] I'm curious, so
I do a lot of photography
in my own time.
- Nice.
- [Rich] I absolutely love it.
How do I grow my audience?
- So on Instagram?
- [Rich] Mhmmm.
- The truth is the way you win
in building an audience is you
have the right content
and you get awareness.
You did the lightweight
one which is the hashtags.
Blows me away how
many people don't do that.
That's just so imperative.
- [Rich] Yep.
- I used to not do it because I
was taking for granted the fact
that I had distribution but
even I was like
fuck that, that's lazy.
Let me like do it right.
But the way to really do it is
every single time you post a
photo you should DM
30 to 50 people who
potentially may share it.
- [Rich] That's interesting.
- Now, but here's the key.
If there's landscape London,
@London and they share shit and
it's 4 million followers.
- [Rich] Mhmmm.
- You have to figure out
how to actually bring them
value when you DM them.
Everybody's DM'ing them.
I get a DM
everyday from 500 times.
So make sure when you see the
accounts you give thoughts to
when you write, when
you forward the photo say,
"Hey, I'm really trying
to get some exposure," like
straight up man, right?
- [Rich] Yeah.
- I'm trying to get some
exposure if there's anything
I can help you with they may
look and go oh hey mate why
don't you give us
10 other photos that
we'll just use for ourselves.
We won't even credit you.
We need more content and
you'd be thrilled to do that on
an account that has 900,000
followers that's gonna tag you
on your photo.
- [Rich] Yeah, absolutely.
- That's the game.
- [Rich] That's a good one.
- Good.
- [Rich] Appreciate that, man.
- Yeah. Good luck, man.
Yeah. Reach out any time.
- [Rich] Will do.
Thanks Gary.
- Thank you.
("Don't Leave Me" by Nik Dinev)
Anything that hasn't or anything
from a higher level or anything
that you're curious about?
- [Woman] We've been talking
recently a lot about just since
yesterday with the
YouTube announcement and is
this the end of TV?
- I think no but I think that
if it's the end of TV for the
people in the
media landscape who think
that's the end all, be all.
You're lucky.
I think you're more similar to
somebody who was in their 20s in
1940, 1950 and watched all these
different changes and then
that became the
market for 50 years.
I think that's what we'll see a
little bit though I don't think
there'll ever be a run because the
technology's gonna change so
much in VR coming in 10, 15
years on the consumer side.
But I do think the YouTube
announcement was interesting.
I haven't read deep into
it but I'm excited about it.
- [Carrier] Hi, Carrie.
- Good to see you again.
Officially.
- Hi.
- How are things?
- [Carrie] Good, thank you.
Good, busy.
("Don't Leave Me" by Nik Dinev)
Writing is a talent.
- Yeah, yeah, it's always ideas.
- If you write it on a wall.
Vayner has always been very
digital forefront even for
digital but I never it's
unbelievable how I never--
- Yeah.
- the only thing I ever worried
about if somebody came from a
more traditional place is that
they held subjective
things at a higher regard.
- Right.
- But by the way that
happens to digital natives.
- Yep.
- So to me it's not the digital,
traditional thing has never
filtered in any
other way than who's just
holding on to historics.
- Yep.
- So I'm with you on that.
That doesn't even
filter in my mind.
- Yeah, make really
good stuff and everything
for a particular platform.
- Yes.
(crosstalk)
And yes, and we have to be
smart and respect the context of
where we deliver it.
- I think context is everything.
- Whole thing.
- I appreciate
having this conversation.
Tells you when it's actually
going well 'cause when you know
that, it starts to change how we
speak and it's being a place for
it too. All cool.
- And so what's your biggest
observation about the difference
here than what you've
kind of seen elsewhere,
if anything?
- The flow is much nicer.
Having worked at big agencies
there's a lot of big egos and
stuff like that.
- Yes.
- As I said, I'm east end girl.
I don't think you
have time for stuff like that.
- Yes.
Sounds like I like east London.
- Yeah?
- Is that the east London vibe?
Good, yes.
I hate that shit.
- Yeah, me too.
I think it's a waste of time.
- You know what?
It's a waste of time.
- Mhmmm.
- That's a very good job, Clare.
That's exactly what it is.
- That's it.
- That's exactly what it is.
- We could be good friends.
- Yes, we are.
Speed is the only thing that
matters and opinions predicated
on people's
insecurities and ego,--
- Absolutely.
- slow shit down.
- Absolutely, completely agree.
- Good for you.
That's good.
That's exactly right.
I'll give you a
good piece of advice
I wish somebody (inaudible).
Number one, nothing changes.
Humans stay the same so don't
ever think that technologies
gonna make the human change.
They're gonna adapt to it but
the core principles of human
behavior are very
tried-and-true.
- Yeah.
- Number two, everything
takes longer than you think.
- Yeah. True.
- When I was, how old are you?
- 28.
- 28, man, you look good.
Going a little younger,
when I was 21,
22 when I launched
WineLibrary.com in 1996,
I said by the year 2000
everybody's gonna come into
Wine Library with
a phone that's gonna,
and I didn't say smart, that's
gonna understand the prices of
everything is what I said.
And so I better
have the best prices.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] It is 2017 you know and
you know it's 21 years later and
almost nobody walks in to my
store and uses their smartphone
to look up prices.
Occasionally.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] So, AI is right.
VR is right.
The technologies there.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] The consumer adaption,
the adoption by the consumers is
what people underestimate
because it's why we're not using
Google Glasses and
Spectacles at scale.
Our behaviors
are tough to change.
- [Man] Yeah, definitely.
- [Gary] They will over time.
- [Man] Yeah.
- I need to run.
- No worries.
- We should
continue this conversation.
- For sure.
- I think you're right.
I think there is
something to do be done.
Listen, you have my inbox.
It's Gary@VaynerMedia,
let's start communicating.
I'll email you back
my cell phone number.
Actually, I'll give
it to you right now.
Anything I can answer for you?
- Yeah, I mean, I've
worked at small agency,
I worked at a really big one.
- Yes.
- And during my time there
there'd be a shift in clients.
Like they're taking their
business away from the bigger
agencies loads of red tape,
loads of process and
they go to smaller,
more agile agencies like
VaynerMedia but even smaller
than VaynerMedia so I just
wanted to ask what's your POV on
where the agency model's
going in the next five years.
- I don't know.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I don't care to be very frank.
I just want them to come to
us because we'll be the best
version of whatever it is.
- [Man 2] Right.
- I think pendulum
always goes
independent, conglomerate.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- Independents get
bought up by the conglomerates.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- I think we'll be the biggest
independent shop in the world.
- [Man 2] Cool.
- And that's it.
Just want to, whether
they're bigger than us or
smaller than us but I think when
David and Goliath fight it's
very important that both of
them work on their strengths.
I think it's crazy when
Goliath loses to David.
Goliath should
never lose to David.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- That means bad strategy.
- [Man 2] Absolutely.
- When we're Goliath
so like us versus Luca
like if he was still doing it,
I would really make
sure we're fucking huge.
Step on his face and kill him
and if we're David 'cause it's
us verse WPP like
get a fucking rock and
put it in his fucking eye.
I don't really care if on the
big guy or the little guy
I just care to win.
- [Man 2] Cool.
- So you know that's
how I think about it.
Like whatever I have to do,
I'm always gonna do that.
That's what I've always done.
- [Man 2] Yeah.
- But it's really hits my radar
like where you are like I don't
know what I was like
the other day it was like
why do I actually know what
Ryan's up to and in life?
No, no, I'm
seeing a lot of shit.
I think I subconsciously
am like filtering it.
And I'm like do I like
Ryan more than I think?
This is literally
what I said to myself.
- Second time in London.
What a rarity it is.
- [Rook] I just
bumped into GaryVee.
This is mental.
- How are you?
- This is mental.
I'm cool.
- Good man.
Real pleasure.
- Vaynerchuk!
- Yes sir! How are you?
- How long you in London?
- I have an office here.
This is where
VaynerMedia's office is.
- [Rook] You're lying.
- Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, how are you?
What's your name?
- I'm Rook.
- Rook.
- Nice to meet you.
(inaudible) I bought
your book. I listen.
- Thank you, brother.
It's real nice to meet you, man.
- Gary Vaynerchuk,
Gary Vaynerchuk,
remember GaryVee?
I showed you his video, yeah.
- (laughs) He's on the phone.
Got it?
- Okay.
- You off, yeah?
- Yeah.
- Man, how long
you in London for?
- I'm actually going to
Hamburg, Germany right now.
I was here for like six
hours but I'm here often.
- Okay, we'll do
that thing again.
You know you did
that meet and greet.
- I'm gonna, I'm gonna.
- Do that again.
- I will.
- This is the best.
- Thank you for saying hello.
- GaryVee!
- [Gary] (laughs) Take care.
The DailyVee part was perfect.
That's the perfect
scene for the opening.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- The end, you know?
- [DRock] I wasn't recording.
- [Gary] You're kidding.
By the way, I knew
you were kidding.
Didn't fall for it.
Swear to God.
Wrapping up the
day here in Hamburg.
Big day tomorrow,
Internet Rock Stars
Conference, excited.
Got a little bit of a chat.
Pretty intense day.
I don't even know is today the
same day as Detroit in theory?
I guess in some
weird way we're in Detroit.
I guess in some weird
way we're in New York,
Detroit, London and
Hamburg all I guess in
like a day and change.
So it's been a
wild 24, 36 hours.
Very productive
really enjoyed my time with
Dan Gilbert and those guys.
I guess that is
the prior episode.
I guess today, it all blurred.
London was super great.
Had a great client meeting,
time with the employees.
("Hit Em" by I Am D)
Well it's not a tour.
The tour is what
makes it seem expensive.
It's the detox,
it's the how do
you actually get it,
come into Vayner, spend 11 hours
get real detailed on paid media.
Real details on influencers.
Real, like just the details of
all the stuff we're putting out
on social in a
Vayner way with experts.
Right, the content.
Yeah, I mean, and access, right?
Like what happens when it's
Tony Robbins with you for
an hour and it's only 10 of you.
Or it's me.
VaynerMedia is going to be doing
something similar to Disney
and--
- [DRock] Zappos.
- Zappos which is
tour and consulting for
the day at VaynerMedia.
So come in at 8 A.M.,
leave 7 P.M.,
11 hours $10,000 a head.
You get to tour
the office and then
you get 11 hours
of content in detail.
Influencer marketing,
video production,
strategy, workshops jamming.
Only 10 people at a time and
just get the Vayner experience
in a digital marketing day that
I'm trying to figure
how to make ROI positive.
We're filming it.
We're doing a bunch of stuff.
We're gonna interview
all of you one by one.
So they can get
content out of it.
The manifesto thing.
We're getting
real close to that.
Gonna get that done?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You got three
good pieces, right?
About to put out a massive
video called how to start.
So many of you are stuck.
Haven't started your thing
but we're gonna
figure that out.
Alright, we're here.
Got to run through the airport.
Hope you guys are well.
Hamburg, Germany I'm on my way.
London, thank you
for the six hours.
Detroit, thank you
for the two hours.
Oh and the
Irish keynote is up
and it is a beast.
If you have not seen my keynote
from Dublin you're missing out.
You need to check that out.
AskGaryVee.
("Hit Em" by I Am D)
And now I'm just
getting to Hamburg but
really it's the kind
of stuff you wouldn't see.
You know, this would
have been a fun episode....
Eventually I'll have
start recording what
I do on my phone.
Lot of action in the phone
today from airport to airport to
airport to hotel to hotel.
Just getting a lot done
with the senior team, a lot.
A lot of focus on new product
offerings from VaynerMedia.
A lot of client strategy stuff.
A lot of revenue realization.
Just nerdy
business stuff of running.
You know, I think sometimes when
you guys watch this you forget
that I'm running a
100 and now with PureWow,
we're gonna be $150 million-plus
conglomerate with
Vayner X so pretty busy.
(group laughter)